is our guest this week on newsmakers to
talk about the turmoil in the US
financial markets Neil Irwin of the
Washington Post and dawn kopecki of
Bloomberg News are here to question him
Congressman Frank if we could start
getting your initial reaction to what
President Bush just said in his news
conference about the need for billions
of US taxpayer dollars to be put into
the financial system well I didn't hear
the news conference I can tell you what
we heard from secretary of treasury
Paulson in Federal Reserve Chairman
Bernanke and it's an idea which I have
been advocating but before we get to the
idea we need to understand why we are in
this situation we have some bad choices
to make the alternative to doing
something now which will put some
taxpayers dollars at risk is to allow
the economy to continue to deteriorate
which we know will cost us far more in
taxpayer dollars the problem is this for
decades now as the financial community
has been innovating and coming up with
new ways to make money and finance
things we have had a philosophy pavilion
Washington says don't regulate don't
have the government intervene the market
knows better Dick Armey the former
Republican majority leader said markets
are smart and government is dumb Alan
Greenspan was given the authority to
regulate subprime mortgages and refuse
to use it because he said the market
knows better the consequence of this
failure to regulate has been a series of
bad decisions by the private sector
obviously not all the decisions were bad
but enough bad decisions were made so
that enough bad debt has accumulated and
it's now choking the system and
unfortunately we have to respond now we
also have to promise ourselves at the
beginning next year we will adopt rules
that will prevent these kind of bad
decisions were being made but in the
near term we have two options one do
nothing and let this market deteriorate
and let jobs be lost and let people not
be able to get loans people not be able
to buy cars people not be able to shop
in storage because that's what happens
when credit dies or we can't put up some
federal money to buy up the paper and
one of the things we will be doing in
is trying to respond to the
administration proposal which I welcome
i think it is important but in ways that
will make sure that it is as friendly to
the to the taxpayers and as much in the
public interest as is possible in these
circumstances dawn kopecki hi chairman
Frank what did Bernanke and Paulson tell
you about the structure of this and the
size last night I was hearing reports
that that the mortgage-backed securities
program would be about 800 billion and
the money market fund would be about 400
billion what were they telling you about
the size of it and how it would be
structured well I didn't hear anything
that would amount to 1.2 trillion we
didn't hear they were in the hundreds of
billions you just gave figures that
would add to 1.2 trillion as the
structure I think that one's pretty
clear we're going to have to essentially
go I think with the Treasury Department
because this is an emergency situation
things have deteriorated much more
rapidly than almost anybody had thought
and you just don't have time to set up a
whole new entity now it's also not
necessary some people have talked about
well what about the old Resolution Trust
cooperation but that wasn't anything
that bought real property that in real
physical buildings and you need sort of
a custodian of those you need people to
watch them to maintain them etc what
we're talking about now is the Treasury
Department probably buying up a paper
Security's bad debt and there's not as
much need for separate entity and
there's a speed factor so I think we are
talking about giving explicit statutory
authority to the Treasury as to the
dollars we're waiting to see what they
think mr. chairman you uh we all know
that the Congress often has a hard time
doing anything quickly let alone
something that's expensive and this
complicated are you really confident
this can be done in a week and what are
the potential challenges in doing yes
I'd ask you to go back and read but many
of the people in the media wrote about
our inability to move quickly when the
stimulus came up and there's a similar
pattern here the notion of the need for
stimulus really came out of speaker
Pelosi and the House Democrats and we
got that done very quickly confounding
people's views I am reasonably certain
that the house will have passed this by
the end of the week we are going to get
the administration's proposal today
they're already conversations our
Committee and Senator dodge committee
committee chairs are working closely
together we have some things we're going
to want to do we want to make sure that
as we buy up mortgage securities which
is essentially what they're talking
about we do in a way that will
facilitate our ability to diminish
foreclosures this can bring a couple of
objectives together because it's been
this foreclosure cascade that's been at
the root of this problem and so this
gives us a chance we will now be the
owners we've been doing a lot of
jawboning to the people who hold the
mortgages please make it easier don't
foreclose it's not the interest of the
whole society for there to be these
foreclosures we will now to a great
extent own a lot of these properties
along with Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
which is now under federal control a
large bank indymac under the control of
the FDIC I think this will give us the
leverage to do some things that
substantially diminish foreclosures we
will work to put that in there but I I
am pretty confident that we will have a
a bill through the house by the end of
the week and Senator Reid Senator
McConnell other members of the Senate
the senator Dodd talked about doing this
quickly I'm sure what will be done
before we adjourned it may push your
German back from September 26 into the
next week but I don't have much doubt
that this will get done within two weeks
or less chairman Frank do you agree with
your counterpart in the Senate chris
dodd that the u.s. is or was days away
from a complete meltdown of the US
financial system i don't know how many
days how complete but we were in danger
of very serious problems and people
should understand where we talk about
we're not just talking about somebody on
Wall Street losing money I met on Monday
with one of the leading financial people
whose company does a lot of financing of
auto loans he said to me we are in
danger of not having the money to
finance an auto loans which means they
couldn't sell cars which means
automobile salesman go out of work which
means people can't make cars so yes i
agree with chris todd that we were in
danger of there being enormous damage to
the financial system and again I want to
stress it is clear where we got here by
a failure to regulate the financial
markets play a very valuable role
innovation is very important but we
should have learned from the New Deal we
should have learned from back when
Theodore Roosevelt and Woodrow Wilson
had to respond you cannot have a
situation in which you have massive
innovation
and you don't have appropriate
regulation so that you can get the
benefit of it but you don't have the
damage and we just had this philosophy
I've let the markets do what they want
don't restrict capital don't regulate
and we're reaping the the food to that
chairman Frank can you talk a little bit
about what you're told regarding the
markets this week I understand that
there were a lot of money market funds
where redemptions were in the tens of
billions of dollars and and Wall Street
firms were actually running out of cash
to to make good on those redemptions and
we're having trouble selling paper to
raise the funds can you elaborate a
little bit on what you were told about
the The Wall Street reaction this week
well pretty much what you've been told
we don't get secret information it
wouldn't be a good idea for individual
companies to be discussed secretary
Paulson did yesterday tell me he was
very troubled I'd spoken to them on
Sunday he and Chairman Bernanke and then
again yesterday he made it very clear
that he was very troubled by the well
join well kids would happen they had
intervened for Bear Stearns they
intervene for Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
oh that's a little different situation
because it was a federal role there then
over the weekend they helped arrange or
encourage bank of america to buy a
limited by this merrill lynch but with a
condom any brothers it was interesting
if you go back to the papers on monday
which seems a very long time ago now
there was a celebration and a lot of
self-congratulation in in conservative
circles we finally let the market work
we are not intervening will let the free
market have its habits to sway that
lasted a day I'm thinking of finally
resolution to declare September 15 free
market day because that was the only day
in which this Conservative
administration sort of stuck with the
free market and what happened was the
market reacted very badly so they said
okay we better get involved and they put
85 billion dollars into AIG and that
didn't work and that's what convinced
everybody that there needed to be
something about systemic i will say that
i had been feeling that way for some
time and you know here's the other thing
that we have to be clear we're not
talking about no intervention or this
kind of intervention we've already seen
this with Bear Stearns and AIG under a
nineteen thirty
statute the chairman of the Federal
Reserve and his board have the power and
they have 800 billion dollars of federal
reserve money that they've made over the
years to go and lend anything to anybody
on any terms if they think it's
economically important so the choice is
not whether you have this kind of
intervention but whether it's done under
rules Congress lays out with some
mandates to protect the public including
some concern about compensation to the
beneficiary companies some concern about
minimizing foreclosures or do you
continue to allow mr. Bernanke to do
this unilaterally and I have a lot of
respect for him I admire him but no one
person in a democratic society without
any congressional or other intervention
should have that power you seem to have
had some reservations about the AIG
action time or at least Chairman
Bernanke as you say his kind of
remarkable individual power and acting
that do you feel that secretary Paulson
and Chairman Bernanke or have too much
concentrated power and was the AIG
bailout the right move well first of all
yes they they did up too much power and
it's not a reflection them if people
going to have power they're about as
good as set as you can have but it was
kind of odd to have the Sun elected
official the chairman of the Federal
Reserve so going around deciding when he
would extend alone and when he wouldn't
what the Secretary of Treasury cheering
him on I told them that we I now thought
of them as the loan arranger and his
faithful companion Paulson going around
and dispensing this money it needs to be
done with rules as I said we think that
we can use this leverage now to reduce
foreclosures well that wasn't part of
their their charter so it is clearly I
think it's necessary to have some
interventions but they should be
regulated as the AIG had one very
particular concern which I raised with
them that Tuesday night when they told
us about it they both said that they
were encouraged pressured to do this
intervention with AIG because so many
foreign governments were worried AIG is
an international company and it works in
many other countries and they told us
that foreign finance ministers in the
European Central Bank were telling them
they had to do this my question was good
then why didn't they put up some money
why was it all 85 billion at risk and we
hope you can recover this people should
not think this is all down the drain but
there's a
whiskey I don't understand why are 85
billion with with risk and not a penny
from these other countries that are
going to benefit from the AIG
intervention and which don't don't put
anything into it it seems to me that the
government is now kind of used the
nuclear option to try and deal with the
financial crisis that's been out there
for 13 14 months already are we running
out of arrows in the quiver does the
government have enough money in enough
capacity to continue to deal with any
further ripples in this crisis well we
have enough money Quilly you know
someone said to me well no way you're
going to find this money i said well i
was in Congress on September 10 2001 and
I can tell you that there was no money
in the budget for warranty rock there's
somebody found hundreds and hundreds of
billions in the warning rock I think
mistakenly because I think we shouldn't
have done that we're very we're a
society with with money we can find the
money the question is will it work I
hope it will I hope that we will do two
things up again if all we were doing was
this intervention and buying up the bad
debts and not changing the system then I
would be against it this has to be part
of a commitment that we will intervene
to correct the mistakes of the past but
we will also make some rules to prevent
these mistakes from happening again now
that's already begun Alan Greenspan
refused to use the authority Congress
gave him in 1994 to prevent unregulated
entities mortgage finance companies etc
for making the kind of subprime loans
that caused this problem Chairman
Bernanke to his credit after the
Democrats came back into power and
worked with him did you GOI Alan
Greenspan refuse to use exactly that
legislation and is now promulgated rules
that will prevent bed subprime loans
from being made in the future we need to
take that a step further and now say to
hedge funds private equity companies and
investment banks of the running left
that aren't owned by banks you cannot
get so highly leveraged that when you
stumble you bring all other people down
with you you're going to have to have
some capital on hand we are going to
limit the amount that you can you can be
coverage you're going to have to be
careful about what you sell and how you
bundle it in other words if you look at
the big banks they have not gotten into
trouble it's interesting in this climate
the more regulated the institutions were
the better they performed in a
fact we've used the regulated
institutions Bank of America JPMorgan
Chase Barclays Bank in England they've
had to be used to buy up the unregulated
in the AIG situation AIG was a very
prosperous company with insurance
factors and those insurance companies
are very highly regulated in this case
at the state level they started to use
the profits that the regulated insurance
companies were generating and we're
spending money and getting involved in
derivatives and Hydra mcgaughys
activities that's where the problem came
so what the federal government is now
going to do is to take the highly
regulated profitable entities and sell
them off to pay off the debts incurred
by the unregulated chairman Frank you
had talked about rules that that the
wall street executives should be held to
some sort of rules here what sorts of
rules are you going to propose or do you
think will be necessary for the
institutions that are able to offload
their bad assets imprudent investments
do you think that executive salaries
should be should be shut how would you
structure that well we can't set all the
salaries in America but here's a problem
with the salaries it is not simply the
compensation it's not simply that they
are very large if is that they give a
perverse incentive and this is something
that the the financial services thought
in England kind of the everybody's model
of a good regulator their head has said
this others have said this the way be
compensation works if you're the CEO or
couple the other top officials if you
make a very risky bet highly leveraged
bet on some obscure security and it pays
off you get a significant bonus if it
doesn't pay off you go home and have a
nice dinner that is it's the kind of
heads I win tails I break even and one
of the things I believe we should do is
to say if you want to participate in
this if you want your company to be the
beneficiary of us buying up this paper
you've got to accept compensation
guidelines that will remove this one-way
street and provide an incentive
structure that does not mean too much
risk taking so that I very much want to
see as a part of this now in the case of
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac by the way
the administration asked us for the
standby authority to intervene we
every to him but we in Congress added
something they didn't answer for and let
me some of the administration was
opposed to we said okay you can do this
but if you use this authority you have
got to set the compensation for the
chief executives and it was that
statutory grant that Congress put in
that the Bush administration did not ask
for that led to the cancellation of the
severance pay for the heads of Fannie
Mae and Freddie Mac and I think those
were decent reasonable people but there
was something unseemly in this situation
about the federal government
intervention and these severance
packages so yeah that's an example of
Congress insisting on some compensation
controls that worked this is c-span's
newsmakers program Barney Frank is our
guest he's chairman of the House
Financial Services Committee Neil Irwin
with the Washington Post dawn kopecki
Bloomberg News here to question him
Congressman Frank do you agree with John
McCain and USA today that the
fundamentals of the economy or sound I
don't know what they mean by the
fundamentals six percent unemployment
well if you mean is America you know
about to become a third world economy no
but I think there was something
fundamentally wrong with our financial
regulatory system and in fact we are not
taught and by the way that's what the
Bush administration concluded that you
couldn't fix this by this is that
intervention but you needed a systemic
intervention to buy things up in the
financial area so I would have to say no
the financial system which is one of the
fundamentals is clearly unsound the
system by which we compensate people who
work for other people for living that is
unsound we have a situation now where
the average workers income real income
adjusted for inflation has been dropping
and that's at a time by the way when the
Federal Reserve will tell you that
productivity has increased so workers
are being more productive but having
less real income and that was in the
most recent federal reserve analysis of
the economy so no the fundamental
principle of workers participating in
the profit in the country that they
helped contribute that's not working so
those are a couple of fundamentals that
I don't think a very sound and I think
we need to change our way chairman Frank
you uh you're a supporter of maintaining
fannie mae and freddie mac's public
mission for many years you have any
regrets do you think that that may have
exposed the taxpayer and the country to
more risks than no because people
misunderstood I I believe that it was
important that they have the public
mission and that regulation was
appropriate there was this myth some
whether the Democrats interfere with
regulation here are the indisputable
facts the Republicans controlled
Congress from 1995 through 2006 not one
thing was done during that period to
increase the regulatory control over
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac in 2005 Mike
Oxley of sarbanes-oxley a man who's
shown the willingness to be tough on the
private sector meta fight to increase
the regulation I supported him he was
the chairman I was the head of the
minority he has since told the Financial
Times that he got what he called the
one-finger salute from the Bush
administration would he try to do in a
reasonable way so he had to give up the
Democrats took power in January of 2007
I became chairman of Financial Services
Committee by April of 2007 that
committee had passed a bill that
tightened the regulation and gave the
administration everything you wanted
they then took another year in a couple
of months for the Senate to catch up
because a part of Republican obstruction
and pick up a going to the way the
Senate works but even with that the
score is 12 years of Republicans zero
improvement in the regulatory structure
of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac 19 months
of the Democrats everything that neat
was needed there was an organization
called FM watch that was critical of
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and said you
got to improve the regulation etc after
the bill passed under the Democrats they
dissolved because they said we'd
accomplish the home agenda now it is
true that unlike the Conservatives I
wanted them around to do some stuff for
low-income housing and middle-income
housing so yes I was for a vigorous role
for Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac but
within the context of better regulation
and as I said as soon as the Democrats
came to power we adopted the kind of
regulation that we were were asked to of
throwing one other thing in 2008 in
January I urge secretary Paulson and I
did this with the approval and support
of speaker Pelosi to take the reform
bill that we had passed in 2007 and make
it part of the stimulus package and I
think he was personally sympathetic but
he couldn't get it through the
administration chairman frank on fannie
and freddie it seems by what the
Treasury is proposing like right now
without congressional authority they can
use fannie and freddie to buy the
subprime assets the real low quality
assets and then treasury has authority
to buy as much MBS in fannie and freddie
as needed to help the economy keep the
company solvent what are fannie and
freddie's role as described to you by
Chairman Bernanke and mr. Paulson what
did they tell you how do they plan to
use fannie and freddie in this context
well we didn't get into all that detail
you know in a 1 hour and 15 minute
meeting with 15 members of congress it
was basically on the conceptual position
but the committee that I chair will be
having hearings on two successive days
next week on Wednesday myself and my
Republican counterparts and pork and
your ski and caramel only the leading
subcommittee chairs have decided to have
a hearing in which we will ask Paulson
and Bernanke to explain what they plan
to do in the big thing the next day we
had a hearing over the schedule with
Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and I can't
tell you exactly how it's going to work
I can't say I agree with your concept
there needs to be an integration here
and we need to not simply use this as a
way to unclog the system so the credit
markets can start functioning again and
create jobs and and and provide the
economic lubrication that we need to
function but we also want to do in a way
that will reduce mortgage foreclosures
so one of the things we are now working
on is how to make sure that we get a
maximum coordination between the federal
government which now runs Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac and the federal government
piece of this and that is high on our
agenda to make that work together
several times today you've mentioned the
role of regulation or the lack of
regulation in this financial crisis it's
I realize it's hard to discuss the fire
code when you're in the middle of a fire
and trying to put it out but what are
your biggest priorities and most urgent
priorities in terms of changing the
financial realm as I mentioned the
biggest single one we passed a bill in
the house to do it after the republicans
refused to do this and then chairman
bernanke did it in 2008 and that's to
put rules that stop irresponsible
subprime mortgages being made again on
behalf of regulation if only
banks and credit unions and thrifts the
regulated entities had originated
mortgages we wouldn't have a crisis we
have it because they were unregulated
entities doing it and the chairman of
the Federal Reserve has agreed with us
and it's already promulgated rules again
the Greenspan refuse to do and could
have done that will stop the subprime
mortgage crisis from occurring beyond
that we want to say that somebody
probably the Federal Reserve but we have
to look at this and this is something
where I think there's now a consensus
has to say to the investment banks we're
going to look at what you do we're going
to limit the amount of leverage you can
put forward we're going to make you have
some capital on hand this theory used to
be well we can regulate banks because
they get deposit insurance and then go
to the federal reserve for help but
investment banks are purely private we
won't regulate them well we now see that
investment banks have used that freedom
so to entangle themselves that they
threaten the whole system and so we
can't allow that simply to go on
unregulated so it's it's to the goal is
to put some constraints on risk-taking I
think that's the best way to put it and
in the era in which people lend money
and then sell the right to get repaid
rather than collect the repayments
securitisation it turns out there are
not constraints on on risk in plain
language too many people in lending
money to other people who can't pay them
back and then multiplying the right to
do that in ways it cause serious pumps
so that's that's the major piece of this
it's to give the Federal Reserve
probably that power and by the way when
I became the chairman what I was about
to be chairman of this committee in 2006
after the election when I was most
hearing from conservatives even frankly
from people in the bush administration
was you've got to deregulate more we're
driving people away some of those who
are now talking about that now agree
that we need to have more regulation
Chairman Bernanke at the recent speech
at Jackson Hole Wyoming came out for
exactly what I'm talking about secretary
Paulson has talked about that we need to
put some constraints on risk-taking by
the unregulated entities the hedge funds
private equity and the investment banks
chairman Frank two questions quick do
you think gramm-leach-bliley that
allowed banks insurers and brokerage
firms to commingle was a mistake and
what do you think about chairman Cox's
short selling rule
first I voted against when we finally
it's not I don't think what it did was
wrong but it didn't do enough we remove
some of the restrictions that I think
had already been eroded Frankie by
reality but we should have put some new
rules in so my i voted against
gramm-leach-bliley that of course is the
pilgrim who has been John McCain's chief
economic advisor through his career and
I I think we could have put more
regulations in there on the short sale I
think the short sale will came up a
little short we should be tougher on
that I think you should have gone all
the way to say you simply cannot engage
in short selling until you fully owned
the the piece I do think that short
selling irresponsible short selling a
naked short selling that that has eroded
further this situation and again this is
the philosophical view that says don't
regulate so they took all the wraps off
short selling they are out unrestricted
short selling even if people didn't know
what they were short selling and I think
that's contributed to the
destabilization Barney Frank is chairman
of the House Financial Services
Committee he's been our guest on
newsmakers Thank You chairman thank you
dawn kopecki Neil Irwin Barney Frank one
of the first things he said was monday
was a long time ago how fast is this
moving astonishingly fast I think the
same is true for those of us who've been
writing about it we can barely get our
heads around one of these interventions
or one of these actions before another
massive and unthinkable thing has
happened it is an astonishing week and I
said earlier I the government has taken
the nuclear option here and and now
we're going to see whether that works
yeah i mean i think that investors
started losing confidence as they
started seeing numbers coming out from
wall street with the AIG bailout and the
lehman bankruptcy they started to get
getting concerned about their money
market funds because those are not
federally insured the Federal Deposit
Insurance Corporation was going out
saying put your money into FDIC insured
banks but money markets are not and what
you saw were billion tens of billions of
dollars of people pulling it out of of
JP Morgan Morgan Stanley Merrill Lynch
and what it left it left those companies
you know in a scramble for cash to come
up with extra funds to cover those
redemptions
and they had problems getting the cash
they had problems selling paper to raise
money for the cash and you really saw an
actual liquidity crisis unprecedented on
Wall Street that I believe is
precipitated this chairman Frank talked
about a couple hearings that his
committee is holding next week what's
going to come out of those I believe
that the regulators will face a lot of
tough questions as to what they knew
when they knew it why they didn't act
sooner Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
analysts for years have you know laughed
at their risk-based capital rules have
laughed at the fact that they could use
assets and count them as regulatory
capital that weren't actual money their
regulator knew this and didn't do
anything I think they're going to face a
lot of tough questions about that as
well as the wholesale you know
reconstruction of financial regulations
as we know it it'll be interesting week
the challenge is that we are still in
the middle of this crisis Congress next
week will still as we heard be trying to
figure out the details of this this
program to buy up these mortgage-backed
securities at the same time they'll be
having hearings with Chairman Bernanke
with the secretary Paulson and others
trying to assess what all this means and
and where things go from here it'll be
another hectic week next week and who
knows how it will shake out when do you
foresee legislation actually being
enacted there was a everybody was
singing Kumbaya last night all the
congressional leaders including some who
are fairly conservative and have been
very skeptical of government
interventions were seeing positive
things about about a kind of idea of
bipartisan cooperation on that it hasn't
it's not that that hasn't happened
before as chairman Frank mentioned with
the stimulus package back in February
also with when when secretary Paulson
asked for authority to put govern money
into Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac in July
congressman very quickly and very
bipartisan Lee in a very bipartisan way
we'll see whether that's the same is
true this week the key to passing
legislation quickly in Washington is to
keep members panicked and keep them kind
of ignorant if they can get this through
without a lot of details leaking without
the press being able to pick it apart by
you know early next week I think it has
a chance of passing very quickly
at the same time it's Congress and
they're not known for their efficiency
we've seen you know times like this
where everybody's been on board and at
the last minute one little detail one
single senator has held up major reforms
that could also happen the risk your
think about what happens if something
goes wrong in Congress and this thing
doesn't pass markets up something like
700 points in the last 24 hours it's a
very risky situation if Congress is
unable to move on this at this point now
that now the expectation of some kind of
action is built into financial markets
so you would expect if nothing happens
legislatively for the market to tank I'm
reluctant to predict what financial
markets will do especially in this
environment but but it's a very
significant risk in the past with the
Fannie and Freddie legislation what
happened was Washington did something
there was a quick rally and then as
analysts read the fine details and
realized that it was just a bunch of
smoke and mirrors everything tanked
there there the spreads which is the
cost of their debt came in so it lowered
their debt costs initially but then the
reason why Paulson did what he did a
week and a half ago was because their
debt spreads were as high as they were
before the announcement in fact it made
things worse in the markets so there is
the possibility that even if they do
something they do something quickly once
Wall Street once once you know Chinese
officials read the fine details they
might realize that it's actually smoke
and mirrors if they don't have a real
solution that actually gets assets off
the balance sheet there is the risk in
speaking to analysts that it could it
could have a backfire in global
proportions danka pecky Bloomberg News
Neil Irwin Washington Post thank you for
participating in newsmakers thank you
thank you